when elon musk looks at people he
actually
sees computers he looks at you and he's
like
wow chris like look you have the
hardware that you were born with which
is
your brain and the genes you got from
your parents but then there's also the
software the stuff that you consume on a
daily basis the content that you consume
the things that you learn
that constantly upgrade your hardware so
what software are you installing in your
mind on a daily basis and the way i
think about it is like an iphone like
are you operating at the latest iphone
update or are you still on like ios
4. people like elon are constantly
upgrading that hardware he sees the
brain as a tool that's malleable
not something that's fixed and you're
born with
so you you do the profile where you
write a dossier about some of the most
interesting people on earth
was there anyone that comes to mind as a
person who you didn't really know if you
were going to like them
and then after profiling them you ended
up becoming a fan
oh that's interesting okay so one that i
wasn't really sure about
was david goggins who um is this ultra
athlete
uh he went through buzz training uh for
navy seals like
several different times and when i first
came across his story
i was like i don't know this guy just
seems like very
you know all-in aggressive a very uh
like a
like a man's man i was like i'm not sure
that i'll
learn a lot from an ultra athlete um
at the time i was training for a
marathon when i first came across the
story so i was like oh maybe i'll learn
something about like
his uh regimen his routine but what i
ended up finding out that
actually david goggins is one of the
most interesting people to me because
it's not just about physical the
physicality for him
it's very very mental and the fact that
it took him
so long to get in the right mindset to
be able to do the things that he has
done
it absolutely incredible and i think
he's a very very good example
of what somebody who's mentally
resilient uh
is he you know he used to he's faced
everything from racism to physical abuse
to emotional abuse at the hands of his
parents at the hands of his classmates
um he had a very very difficult
childhood and then he used
these like mental techniques to get
more mentally tough and to be able to do
these like physical challenges that he
um imposed on himself what are some of
the techniques he uses
one of them is he calls it the
accountability mirror
so when he weighed like 300 pounds
he was uh he worked as a he was praying
for cockroaches
he um came home one night with this like
massive steak and shake
shake from steak and chick uh and he sat
down to watch tv because that's what he
did every single day
and he came across this documentary on
navy seals
and that's kind of what piqued his
interest to start getting in shape and
turning his life around
but the accountability mirror basically
was he posted sticky notes all over his
mirror
that told him okay for the next day
you're not gonna lie to anybody uh in
order
to protect your own feelings or their
feelings or whatever because we all do
that right like we lie
every single day he wanted to stop lying
to himself and others
so that was a goal he set these like and
another goal was
be able to run one mile and
those are those are super super specific
things because when you look in the
mirror the only person
you cannot lie to is yourself so he it
sounds really harsh
but uh he looked in the mirror the first
day and he said he looked at his
reflection he was like
you're fat you're lazy you're unhealthy
you're stupid
all the things that he believed about
himself
and those sticky notes were his um
kind of the steps he took to change that
narrative so when he looked in the
mirror he was proud of what he was
seeing
what would you ask goggins if you got to
talk to him so many things
well what were some of the things that
you felt were missing like let's say
that you're really trying to dig deep
and getting at the source code of him
what couldn't you find on the internet
that you need to know
about his uh personal life how he deals
with
relationships i know he's engaged but i
know nothing
about uh that journey he
he very much if you read it he kind of
almost sounds like
selfish in the sense of i'm gonna
improve myself to be the best person i
can be
but you rarely see a glimpse of his
uh personal sex relationship status
um and i think that's on purpose i think
he wants to keep that you know uh part
of his life private
but i would be very curious i'm actually
very curious about that with a lot of
people
because i think it's it's easy to look
at them and say
wow look at all that they've
accomplished but like what have they
sacrificed in the process
um i know he's been divorced previously
but i don't know the specifics and to me
i i read the whole like for example not
to go off this tangent but i
i read ashley vance's biography um on
elon musk and my one question
was why is he in this relationship
pattern
uh and it's it probably has a lot to do
with certain insecurities he has it as a
child or whatever
but those were like the tiny glimpses of
that were really
interesting to me uh because i think we
tend to leave
interpersonal relationships out of the
narrative of success
the ruthless thing about
feeling jealous about somebody else and
about people that are high performers
is precisely what you've touched on
there that you don't know what that
person's had to sacrifice
to get to where they are there's this
example i always use have you heard of
eddie hall do you know who he is
strongest man on the planet so he's a
british guy he was the strongest man in
the world
2018 i want to say
and um he was six foot
three 160 kilos
he was on the verge of death basically
he couldn't walk
up like he was just everything about him
was [ __ ] his um
marriage was falling apart his wife was
about to leave him he didn't have a
relationship with his kid he was
probably about to die because of all of
the stresses he was putting his body
under
and then just at the peak of that he won
the world's strongest man
and he said he said as he won it there
and then he was like that's me i'm done
like i've closed the loop i'm now going
to save my marriage i'm now going to
save my
relationship with my daughter and i'm
going to save my own health as an
athlete i'm going to save my own health
and what we look at with someone
like him or like david goggins or like
elon musk
the success that they have is so tightly
bounded within a very narrow domain
and we in 2020 and 2021
we applaud and put on a pedestal
success to such a degree that we're able
to look at someone that has that sort of
a life
and then think that that constitutes
success tiger woods was in a
car accident recently the other day like
that is a man
whose life whose entire life is
epitomized in a car crash
other than the one thing that he's
really really superhuman at doing
he struggles with relationships he had
substance problems he
is injured all the time it doesn't
really seem like he loves himself his
dad abused him for years as a kid
calling him the n-word
he had to say do you know you had a safe
word with his dad
i did not so you know like in rough sex
people have a safe word
his dad would be there on the course
saying you're useless
this racist you're that whatever um
but they had a word called the e word
and it was enough
oh i did read yeah i did in ryan
holidays in one around holiday's books
um but but the sort of common theme
there is
we look at people's performance and
their successes
in such a tight window and the cult of
personality and our
adoration of success means that we're
happy to see someone
nearly die nearly lose their marriage
and really do all of this stuff
because we want them to be the super the
superhero for that thing
um but you don't you you don't want
their life if you were to ask someone
like do you really want to swap with
elon musk
like you don't know he might not have
had an erection in months he might hate
his body when he looks in the mirror he
might not be able to have silence in his
head when he's
when his head hits the pillow at night
like is that the price you really want
to pay to be him
i always say that every time that
let's say you want to let's say you're
just out of college and
you admire somebody and you're like i
would love that life i would love that
career
i would love that path what i recommend
doing
is if you can ideally you would call up
the person or email them and try to
talk to them and ask like okay but what
have you had to sacrifice
like what does this look like because
we're really bad
at predicting our future happiness and
what better way than to find the person
who is already there
that we think has it has it all and ask
them about the process of getting there
if you cannot you know interview them or
meet with them in person
i would try to research every aspect of
their life like that's what i did with
sarah blakely
um try to research every aspect of their
life look at interviews they've done how
do they present themselves how do they
answer questions about their uh current
relationship etc
and then try to draw conclusions about
yourself of like
okay but you're gonna have to sacrifice
you know having kids or
not having time for your kids all that
stuff in order to get there is that
worth it to you if it is
go ahead but like i think it opens your
eyes to a lot of things that you might
not want
we often don't realize that these people
are real humans
like you look at someone like goggins
and you're like that guy's just uh
a dedicated kicking ass [ __ ]
you don't actually realize that there
are these very very human flaws that he
has
absolutely like i would love to know the
last time he was sad
like straight up like wanted to cry i
don't know that because
we all show up as the people that we
aspire to be a lot of times and not
you know the people who we actually are
uh so in like those like super
vulnerable moments and i think
actually i read his book and i think in
there he shares a little bit of that
but most of the time it is you think of
goggins you think this like
hard dude it's different though
when you are talking about a past
sadness
like it's easy for us to say like oh
well five years ago
at the beginning of my journey when i
did this thing because it's basically
talking about not you you're still
creating some distance between yourself
and that
so another question a question that i'd
really love to ask him is
when he looks in the mirror does he
still see someone who's fat and stupid
and
and has all of the problems there's a
certain period of
some formative years where i think we
imprint a particular view of ourselves
into our source code and sometimes
it's very very difficult to deprogram
that um
and yeah i want to know how much all of
the stuff he does now
has fixed all of the stuff he did then
yeah and maybe we'll get into this later
but he uses uh an
alter ego to kind of he used to refer to
the weak
part of himself that he thinks of as
david goggins that's the guy who got
bullied that's the guy who you know was
lazy and unhealthy and whatever and then
he says that's why he says
i was built not born he now refers to
himself as
goggins when he looks in the mirror and
i think that over time like maybe those
two identities reconcile
but in the process i i don't know the
answer to that question does he
sometimes
in certain instances say ooh that was
that was david gaga's like i have to act
like goggins now
yeah so he's distancing himself from the
person that was
that was weak i mean that's one way to
deal with it to basically
bruce wayne and and batman it talking
about elon musk obviously he's a
super enigmatic guy and there's a lot
that's been written about him what was
some of the principles
that you learned that have contributed
to his success i think
uh elon is truly
one of the most innovative original
thinkers
probably as close of an example that you
can get to somebody like that in our
generation
certainly um he a lot of people call him
crazy and insane because his ideas are
so
out there but that's kind of what it
takes to be an original thinker and a
lot of people don't realize that
um i read uh one of my favorite things
that i've read is tim
urban on weight but why he did this
whole thing on elon musk and his company
neuralink
i think it's as long as a book but it's
a series of blog posts
so one of the things he says that has
kind of stuck
actually two things uh two things he
said that stuck in my head is
one um when elon musk looks at people
he actually sees computers he looks at
you
and he's like wow chris like look you
have the
hardware that you were born with which
is your brain and
the genes you got from your parents but
then there's also the software the stuff
that you consume on a daily basis the
content that
you consume the things that you learn
that constantly upgrade your hardware
so what software are you installing
in your mind on a daily basis and the
way i think about it is like an iphone
like
are you operating at the latest iphone
update or are you still on like ios
4. um some people choose to consume
junk that kind of keeps them there but
people like elon are
constantly upgrading that hardware to
make it um
a tool that's he sees it he sees the
brain as a tool that's malleable
not something that's fixed and you're
born with the other thing that tim irvin
writes is that
in terms of the original thinking that
elon is
truly like a chef he operates like a
chef
who invents recipes who's a trailblazer
who doesn't copy
other things the cooks are
the majority of society who basically
there's a blueprint
they follow that blueprint which is the
recipe and they create something
sort of new but not truly original um so
so i always think of that like every
time i think i'm being original i'm like
eh i i think there was a blueprint for
this and i'm just kind of revising it a
little bit but it's not a
truly original thought i
know that you're a fan of mental models
and i came up with one the other day
that i think relates to that
so it's called the common thought raiser
your thoughts are far less unique than
you think they are if you've had a
thought assume that at least some
significant minority of other people
also have done absolutely i
so okay can i give you an example of
that um
when i first left fortune to work on the
profile full-time
i my original goal was
oh well this is great so right now i
curate a bunch of profiles in this
newsletter
over time i'm going to start writing
original profiles
and but like my thinking was so limited
in that
i came uh to the table with the
assumptions that
an original profile was text a headline
text maybe a photo some more text maybe
a video that's relevant some more text
that's that's what a profile was that's
what i wrote for fortune that's what i
wrote a cnn like
all those things um had been defined way
before
my time but who is to say that a
profile looks or that a block of text is
a profile
we saw what um brandon stanton does with
humans of new york
that's those are profiles but they are
profiles
done in a different format so then i was
like oh my god like okay
so then i asked my question like what
makes a profile
a profile how can you distill the
essence of somebody into something that
people will learn from or that kind of
shows who they are as a person and the
truth is
it could be in the form of audio it
could be in the form of video it could
be in the form of something that doesn't
exist yet
but it was only when i started thinking
that way that i was like oh
interesting like i could help define
what that is
uh but i still haven't gotten an answer
to that i'm still thinking about it but
i think that that's like
the types of questions we have questions
we have to ask ourselves instead of just
assuming we know what something is
being like oh wait a second who decided
that a profile is a block of text one of
the things that i find
works so well for me in terms of
personal development is when i question
my assumptions
and the weird thing about that is you
can only really do it a couple of times
a year
because it's very difficult to question
your assumptions when you're busy doing
get taking care of the urgent
and the important but at the end of each
year people might
do an end-of-year review and feel this
that they actually think like well
hang on i i've had this thing that i've
had in my morning routine or this way
that i make my food or this particular
format in which my day is constructed
whatever it might be do i actually have
to do that like do i
genuinely really need to do that and
when you question those assumptions
that's kind of when everything goes out
and you get to go from
much more first principles perspective
you said that
elon sort of is a true first principles
thinker
and i'd agree do you think there's
anyone from history
that would be similar to him is there
anyone that you found or anyone alive
yeah uh from history i think i think you
could say da vinci was a really original
thinker he kind of
uh looked at two disparate ideas
and allowed his brain to make
natural connections between them i think
one of the examples is how he
uh basically was um what was he doing he
threw
a rock into a well and he saw the the
ripples in the water
at the same time that a church bell went
off and he heard the sound and how
it kind of like was really strong and
then it dissipated so that kind of led
to his theory
that sound travels in waves um
i mean that's that's pretty original um
but
you have to let your brain kind of do
the work for you i think another
really really original thinker that i
was inspired by is grant akitz who is a
chef
he has a restaurant in chicago called
alenia multiple times it's been called
the best restaurant in the world
he um he basically challenges
every sort of assumption that's been
around forever
uh kind of like for example uh
he gets inspired by everything so he'll
go to a museum look at
uh art on the wall and say why can't i
eat off of that
so okay then he like um puts
he creates the whole table to look like
a
painting that you can eat off of but
also
he's like um who why do plate
manufacturers decide
like how i'm gonna display my food and
um i don't want to be limited to that
and why do we make this motion uh when
we eat which is like how we eat always
um so he scrapped that he created
something that's like a floating food
when it floats to you you can eat it it
disrupts
the motion of eating from uh hand to
mouth
which is crazy um but i i just i like
people like that
because yes they're original thinkers
but i think to your point a little bit
when you're busy you don't have time for
that so
uh spotify uh ceo danielle eck
says that he literally bakes that
thinking time into his schedule
where it's uninterrupted time to
question those
those assumptions because i agree like
in the weeks where i'm super busy i
don't have time to think about what a
profile looks like
uh but if you if you give a little bit
of uh distance and time to your brain to
think about those things it really helps
yeah the explore versus exploit paradigm
as james clear talks about
it where you do spend more time but as
we get older and presumably more
successful
or more at least we get more status
around the things that we do we become
entrenched in those thinking patterns in
those working patterns
and um you must see this with your
business as well that
when you find a little bit of success
it's actually really difficult to let go
of that because you're like well no like
that that's actually worked i've been
playing around trying to desperately get
something to go well i finally managed
to do it
and there's this bit of me that's saying
yeah yeah yeah but let's see if we can
do it better and you're like no [ __ ] you
like i've just i've just about managed
to get something to not be terrible
like let's keep going on that he said
about um elon constantly upgrading
his mind what what are some of the
practices that he does
for that to occur um like for example
he'll pick something and he'll start
learning it from scratch like you can't
learn about rockets unless you learn
about physics
uh so he starts from like the he
describes his learning process as um a
tree so you have to start at the roots
before you go to the trunk before you go
through to the branches and the leaves
you can't start with the leaves and then
work your way backwards
uh and the leaves being the minute
details uh
of you know rockets so i think that's
one
uh grant akitz makes his staff
blow up the menu every six months no
matter how successful it is
and so that's like that's the whole
thing because he believes that
success can lead to complacency and when
you're complacent you can't be original
you can't be innovative
so no matter how great it is and his
whole staff was like oh come on man like
this is the best menu we've created
and he's like nope gotta innovate um and
the other person who does this uh that i
mentioned already is
uh humans of new york create our brand
in saturn he started
um the humans of new york has evolved so
much that he
said that criticism that he received
about humans of new york two years ago
never applies to today because he's
evolved
it so much he went from uh just
photographing people on the street to
adding a little quote to doing a whole
interview
to doing a book to doing a profile
series kind of
uh one person several posts then when
the pandemic hit
he started doing them remote and he was
like wherever the wind was blowing i was
always willing to take what i'm working
on right now and whatever has been
successful
drop it and move in that direction and i
think that as long as
you keep in your mind the overall
mission and brand promise of what you're
working on
is as long as you keep that in mind and
you always deliver on that
the the how you get there can vary
and i think not a lot of people are
willing to drop everything and go in a
different direction
is that how you've tried to apply this
to the things that you do
absolutely always um whenever i get
criticism uh cat cole says this she says
whenever somebody criticizes something
you do no matter how rude or the manner
it's in
if it feels mean or offensive or
whatever the first thing you should do
is just assume that it's true if you
approach your life as like
you just assume it's true then you can
be like oh maybe like there's a
grain of truth here and to be honest
chris like
at fortune i wrote a daily newsletter
and the feedback
was brutal especially in the very early
days i
you know i didn't have such thick skin
um so
things would get to me and i would
remember that damn like am i not
a good writer but once you hear
something over and over again you're
like okay
let me try this other thing and if it
doesn't work like maybe i'm just
it's not for me but i found that um
just taking the feedback evolving what
you do
and then looking back and be like was
that a good decision or did i just do
that because
i got nervous and whatever it helps
inform
a lot about uh your business and
it helps you like it helps you not get
stale
yeah it's an interesting one that i um
i vacillate with my opinions around
criticism some of the things and some of
the changes i've made
have actually been born out of stuff
that people say
um the challenge i think i would have
with at first
going from base this is true as opposed
to base
this person is a complete idiot is that
the vast majority of stuff that i see on
the internet falls into category two
than category one
um and i had seth godin
on the show actually and he was talking
around criticism and he said that he
removed comments from his blog
because he knew that if he left comments
on his blog he would make
each post just a little bit longer with
a couple more caveats in
and he'd have some more prepositions in
there and he'd try and sort of assess
what people
he was second order writing the article
to debate against the point at which he
thought people were going to and they
got rid of it and people were like
you can't get rid of the comments on the
blog it's a blog he's like well no i
just did
and um and now he's like my writings got
linearly better ever since i had
um yeah i think criticism and the way
that people deal with it
is quite individual but if you could get
away with taking it
like that i think that it's very
beneficial so hold on
and let me just add this very important
thing that
it matters the source right like be
mindful of the source
i probably don't listen to 99 of the
things that people on twitter say to me
probably because they are not people who
read my work on a
weekly basis they are not people who
actually took the time to give me
mindful feedback
i think like seth said okay shut down
the comments
but the people who go through all the
hurdles to find your email to get into
your inbox to share something thoughtful
those are the people i'm like oh okay
like you actually took time
and you went through all these obstacles
to get to me i should probably listen
yeah yeah the source is incredibly
important
absolutely i mean i got this message
i still haven't replied to it still in
my message requests
uh on instagram this guy identified a
bunch of stuff to do with the previous
guest that i'd had on
and gave me this really long rebuttal
but
it was super well thought out very
complimentary very very mindful
and i just thought like i need to the
reason i haven't replied is because i'm
not i can't just sort of dismiss this i
can't decide
delete it or say like thanks mate cheers
give me a give give me a review on on
itunes
like so yeah i had to i'm gonna go back
to that but very much i think you can
you can take it take it with a pinch of
salt when it's needed
you looked at um the rock as well and
then he tweeted you like first
off what's it feel like to have the rock
tweet you and then what did you learn
from profiling him
insane um so so the rock
is this actually what version how did we
end up in a version of the simulation
where we're talking about
when the rock tweeted me like it's so
wild
so okay so the rock
so okay so i published these uh i call
them the profile dossier
which is deep down an individual person
comes out every wednesday
i do a lot of these i've probably done
over 50 now every single week
for almost a year and the
typically the people um are across
industry entertainment sports business
fashion whatever it may be but the one
thing that i pride myself on
is there's a section in that little
profile i write about them
called techniques to try so these are
super practical things you can learn
from people like elon musk or charlie
munger sarah blakely
and i distill them and i'm like here's
what you can learn from the way this
person sees the world
but typically they're very very specific
i wanted to do a profile on the rock
because i thought he was really
interesting but when i kind of was
writing it i was like oh this feels a
little bit like
soft like it feels motivational and
inspirational
but there isn't that element of super
super specific practical things right
um so so i was like i mean it's good
i like it it's fine but i figured i was
like you know what i'm gonna publish
this on um
christmas day which i think was a
wednesday uh when like
people are you know they're not really
reading they're with their family like
this one i didn't feel like it was my
best work but the thing i learned
is that you can't always plan success
and um i i think david pearl said this
once he said something like everything
you put out into the world
whether it's a podcast a newsletter or
anything
it is a vehicle for serendipity
you don't know whose eyes it's gonna get
in front of who's gonna listen to it
who's gonna forward it to the rock
uh so what i didn't know is i tweeted
my dossier on the rock and i tagged him
on twitter
as i do with everybody that i profile if
they have a twitter account
what i didn't know is that the rock like
manages his own social media
and he happened to see it in his
mentions
and actually um i tweeted it on
christmas eve that it was coming out the
next day and he was like can't wait to
read it paulina and i was like oh my god
what and then the next day i published
it
tagged him again he actually read it not
only did he read it and like it he
tweeted about it four times he has like
15 million twitter
followers then he put it on his facebook
then he put it
on instagram a week later he has like
more than 220 million
uh people and i was like literally you
couldn't pay
anybody to do better marketing for your
work than this
um and it just i mean
it was awesome but it just goes to show
that you just
if you take that small extra step of
tagging somebody on twitter or
forwarding the email to their people you
just
never know where like you'll get quote
unquote lucky
how do people avoid the perfection trap
when doing that because
trying to cover all of the bases can
often end up with people not shipping
work
at a pace which is required to iterate
and grow
and i don't know whether i would be
interested to know whether the vast
majority of people
undershoot and ship too fast at too low
of equality or overshoot and ship too
slowly at too high of a quality
but thiago forte had this quote which
you may have seen
from the other day which is unbelievable
and he said a paradoxical thing about
people who consistently choose the most
high leverage activity
is their efforts have a rough edged
half-assed quality because polishing
things to perfection
is a low leverage activity
absolutely so good and then this other
guy replied and said perfectionism is a
nice
way to hide from shipping at the pace
necessary to find what works
yes oh my god um okay so
i i think i realized this when i
realized that
um doing good work is actually the enemy
of perfection
and also the perfectionism mental
construct that doesn't really exist
honestly to me that rock profile wasn't
perfection to the rock it may have been
like to the fact that i never
interviewed him for this
and he thought his story was well told
enough
to share it with his audience i mean
that's that's a massive compliment right
so for me there is nothing worse
than seeing super talented people who
are waiting
for something to be perfect and polished
and beautiful
until they launch it and they're not um
focusing on
let's like let's like put this out there
see how people react and then the next
version will be much
better because nothing that exists today
exists in its current form without
having to go through that iterative
process
humans of new york started as something
bad it evolved into something amazing
but it would
have never gotten to where it is now if
it hadn't gotten like
if brandon hadn't just started and
gotten all that feedback and learned
oh wait i'm not the best photographer
but i'm really damn good at talking to
strangers
like that's something you learn in the
process and that's why like
honestly i've never been afraid of
somebody
giving me feedback because i know it can
be better but i am afraid
of waiting for something to be perfect
in my mind putting it out there
and then getting crickets and being like
oh well
guess nobody saw my beautiful perfect
thing
yeah no one except for you knows the
potential that you left on the field
absolutely no one at all you
i'm going through a couple of youtube
courses at the moment and one of the
things that they're really trying to
drill into
all of the creators is look even if you
think
that you were a bit tired that day a bit
sloppy
you didn't like your hair you thought
the lines weren't so slick or whatever
it is
no one else knows what it could have
been only you
know what it could have been it's a very
odd asymmetry
like a reverse parasocial relationship
with your own creation
where you're like i'm the only one that
actually knows what it was
supposed to be could have been everybody
else thinks that's just what you put out
there
and if you go about it with enough
gumption and energy they're probably
going to be seduced into thinking
i mean what did we say at the beginning
of this like there are people out there
who can annihilate
their entire life and win it a thing
and people think that they're great like
if they can do that
if they can do that you can probably get
away with thinking
like well yeah maybe it's not perfect
but it's good enough which is what
seth gordon says his rule of thumb is
what talk us through the
specific techniques that you learn from
the rock are you getting up at
4 am and doing kettlebell swings or
something definitely not
um so uh let's see the rock one of the
things he says
is that um he i think this is slightly
uh similar to the complacency that i
talked about
he as a kid he wasn't great
he was arrested he was like stealing
he you know he he did a bunch of things
that he's not proud of
uh but and he failed at a bunch of
things but
he um he says always keep your failures
at the forefront of your mind
and he says like by living life as if
he is one week from getting evicted or
one day away
like you kind of start to realize like
all of us
um you never know what's gonna happen
and it is a very
fine line between your great success and
losing it all
he's been there he's seen what can
happen he had a great like football
career that came to an end due to an
injury you never like tiger woods i mean
god forbid but like who knows what
happened in that car crash and who knows
what the future of his career is
when um when your success depends on
something external that you
could lose it's very very
hard to live in peace um but i think
that
his whole thing is i keep my failures at
the forefront of my mind
because i know what it's like to have
been there
and i'm not afraid to be there again
because i know i can build it back
up or whatever he tells himself but i i
just i think that there's great value in
going through something really really
difficult and not kind of
forgetting about it or shoving it to the
back of your mind
and constantly reminding of your
yourself hey by the way like
things could things could be bad again
but i think i have all the tools
necessary to get through it
that self-esteem is
it's a topic it's a word that i just i
hadn't heard for ages
and then naval tweeted it toward the
back end of last year and said
self-esteem is the reputation you have
with yourself
you'll always know and
we talk a lot about confidence and
charisma and being outgoing and
extroversion everyone's
addicted to talking about whether you're
an introvert or an extrovert yeah but no
one ever actually talks about
self-esteem and it very much is
james clear says um decide the sort of
person you want to be
prove it to yourself with progressively
bigger wins
and yeah that's what self-esteem is
one of the things i've been thinking
about a lot is i've gained a lot of
self-esteem over the last couple of
years
and i want to try and work out where
it's come from because it's quite useful
and yeah and um
i think a big part of it has just been
progressively bigger wins
i did some stuff that i was successful
at but it wasn't
super meaningful to me throughout my 20s
and now i do something
which is pretty meaningful to me and i'm
like okay there's only so many times
that you can succeed in the real world
and your imposter syndrome
still cut through it and say yeah but
you didn't deserve that like
after a while the imposter syndrome just
has to [ __ ] off because you're like well
i just
i i keep on you keep on saying i'm not
going to do it and then
i kind of inevitably at one point i do
get there
um so yes self-esteem and building
yourself up like that
having faith that the future you will
deal with whatever happens like
everybody that's listening to this
podcast right now no matter
all of the catastrophes the late nights
the sweaty sheets the
neurotic thought loops all of that stuff
no matter everything that you thought
was going to end your life
you're here listening to this podcast
absolutely fine like if that isn't a
sign
that you're probably going to be okay
that the thing you're worried about
is probably going to end up all right i
don't know what is
yes and i i call this like the like the
oh [ __ ] moments so
when um i've had many of those but one
that i remember very clearly
is when i was at fortune i was just a
reporter
and um the person who was writing
fortune's daily deal making newsletter
term sheet left
trim sheet is a beast of a newsletter
you gotta go through all the deals you
gotta figure out who's buying who
who's raising funding which firm is
raising a fund like
you're going through all this on top of
that you have to write
something intelligent and some sort of
analysis at the top
for these very important people who are
reading this newsletter
i was acutely aware of this i
did not think i was in any way qualified
nobody knew who the hell i was
and this person left the the writer of
the newsletter left and they're like
well
paulina like literally you're the
closest we have
to somebody who may be able to rate this
but like you're going to be
doing this for the interim while we find
somebody who's
actually um you know can do this and so
i so they asked me right so do you want
to and i was like i really don't
but in my head my head was going no no
no no no and i was like
absolutely i would love to give it a
shot and then i went home and i was like
what the hell have you done but i think
like
the moments for me that build up my
self-esteem are the moments where you
drop me like in the middle of the ocean
and you say swim and i'm like
i i became best friends with google i
called everybody i knew i asked them to
teach me things
i have never learned so much in the span
of like a year
ever um but it proved to me that like if
i
genuinely want to be good at something i
can figure out a way to do it
um typically it's not a learning problem
it's a motivational problem
and um i recently had this conversation
with
carolyn joyce she's a three-time olympic
swimmer
and i talked to her and she felt like
there was this one race it was a
qualifier for the olympics it was her
third one
and she was sitting in this dark room
and she had a really rough year she had
like back injuries like
she was get she felt like she was
getting slower and wasn't at the top of
her game
and she's sitting in this dark room
about to get out on the blocks to race
and she goes i i just felt my mind
just be like ah but like you're not that
fast and like all these negative things
and she's like positive thinking does
not work for me i can't just be like you
know what kara snap out of it like
just be positive so she said the thing
that helps her
is playing a mental movie of exactly
those oh [ __ ] moments the moments where
somebody said
yes you're probably not qualified to do
it but you did it anyway
i think playing a mental movie of those
is much more powerful than
just like faking it till you make it or
telling yourself you can do something
when you have no proof for it
yeah so it's retrospectively looking
back at times when
you thought all holy hell was going to
be unleashed on you
and then somehow you came out on the
other side yeah absolutely
uh i have a buddy who likes to spend a
lot of money
and he he uh always says
future andrew will pay will pay the bill
and
um that's basically the same from a
financial perspective
that he'll spend the money now he'll buy
the bugatti he'll get the business class
flight he'll do the whatever
because he has faith he has so much
faith that future andrew will get it
sorted
um interesting wow like so like faith in
your future self to not be dumb
having having faith in your future self
but i think that can really only come
out of self esteem
and what we see and one of the reasons i
think that we get triggered
by people who have confidence which is
undue
or we believe is undue is that
if you're someone who is more
self-critical
more realistic with your own worldview
it almost feels like that person has got
self-esteem without having done the
stuff to deserve it
you're like well hang on a second that
person gets all of the benefits of
believing in themselves
but they've done even less than me like
how the [ __ ] are they able to believe in
themselves
so yeah i think there's sort of two
maybe two hemispheres to this
one of them is to try and look for
positive outcomes wherever you can
to avoid slipping into a negativity trap
but on the flip side of that
to actually continue to prove these
things to yourself with those small wins
and then to reflect on the times where
you did defeat all of the demons of hell
and come out of the swim meet okay or
get the news that they're done when you
had absolutely no idea about this
particular type of market or
whatever it is and as well that's those
are the things that make us feel alive
like you don't feel alive when
everything's going
fine you feel alive when you left the
dissertation until two days before it
needed to be handed in
or the project the group project and you
order a dominoes at 3am and you're in
the office and you're sleeping under the
desks and then you get up the next
morning and you couldn't believe it but
you smashed it and like go team and high
fives
like that's that's living um
yeah it really is you looked at chris
jenner which
was a surprising one um what did you
learn
there okay so that was i think that was
truly one
where i was like i'm not sure
how much i have to learn from kris
jenner
but come to find out and you have
something to learn from every single
person people often ask me like
are you you know would you ever um
profile someone who isn't well-liked or
well-respected i
genuinely believe there is something you
can learn from every person's experience
and um kris jenner i mean
she is very polarizing people either
love her or they hate her there is very
little like i don't know how i feel
about kris jenner
um because you uh associate her with
uh keeping up with the kardashians what
you
failed to understand is that kris
jenner korea she manufactured the life
that she is living and she was
incredibly strategic
about it uh i mean she started with
uh bruce jenner now caitlyn jenner but
then bruce
she had married um him and he would he
was like trying he
didn't have a lot of money came out of
this olympic career um and she was like
what are you doing like
you can go speak that's how you can make
money you can be a motivational speaker
and he was like i don't know who's gonna
listen to me
so she literally hand-made all these
like press packets
and send them all over the place and got
him all these like speaking engagements
she became his agent
at a time you know where like what like
what do you do how
why are you doing this but she found
ways and so
one thing i believe is that um when
the way because i write these dossiers
without having talked to the person
what i've found is that um this mirrors
a very similar process
is if i was about to interview the
person so i would go through this
research before ever interviewing
someone
but how do you decide like what you
should ask people about
when you hear them say something more
than once
it's probably important to them so pay
attention to that
one thing i noticed about kris jenner
that she kept saying over and over and
over again people didn't press her on
was she said um whenever she was like
over the course of my life i've learned
that whenever somebody says
no that means i'm talking to the wrong
person
it shows a level of persistence that
most people
do not have if you get rejected a bunch
of times you're probably gonna
feel defeated she did not and she had
the benefit of her first marriage with
um
rob kardashian robert kardashian um that
uh basically she she didn't have a
business school
education she was just surrounded by
these like
really successful people so she heard
things and she learned things and it was
solely through the power of observation
and then she was like
all right i can do this myself but i
just admire
the fact that she you know her life
she didn't make great decisions in her
personal life but
over time she found success in this one
area
and you know she she took advantage of
it which a lot of people do
how much do you think she was important
in the
architecture of creating the kardashians
as they are
yeah so uh she once said
uh i'm gonna we got our 15 minutes of
fame my job is to turn it into 30.
she was very very very strategic about
it
um but her initial thought was when they
got the
show on television she was like oh my
god we have these
uh clothing stores this they're gonna
film in our clothing stores we're gonna
sell a whole lot of t-shirts
what she didn't realize is is that you
know
success kind of begets success and then
like the tv show would be big
way bigger than their little clothing
stores but she also understands the
power of distribution
which is why i believe like two of her
kids are maybe billionaires maybe i
okay i have not verified this but um she
they all have businesses
every single one of her kids has a
business and um
even even rob he has a sock business uh
but but the the point is
she understood the value of building an
audience early on in the days of social
media
having an authentic voice talking
directly to the consumer
then that develops an emotional
connection right with the kardashians
you feel like you're part of the family
you're invested emotionally invested
then you wanna buy whatever they have
but once you have the audience
she knew i could put any product in
front of them
and because people are so invested in
it's such a large
uh audience i mean you can you can do
whatever you want
it's it's a really interesting case
study and like marketing and
communications and
it's fascinating but very very integral
to their success
i think i got sent a clip
from husband pompliano talking
about this new way of creating products
for the market that's creator-led an
audience first uh george mac is
currently screaming into his airpods
about what it is because i'm going to
butcher it basically what
i think he was saying was that
originally what you would do is you
would do a little bit of market research
then you would create a product that you
think
fits the market in a age of ubiquitous
uh communication where we can go back
and forth from creator to audience quite
easily
and also as the creator you
form the interests of the audience
what he thinks we're going to see people
doing as
platforms continue to grow and audiences
continue to grow in relationships with
creators
continue to grow is that you'll actually
have someone who comes from an audience
first perspective
here's me with my tic toc account or my
podcast or my youtube channel
and then i'm gonna get to half a million
subs and say okay what what do you want
to learn from me
like what's the teachable course the
skill share the product
the whatever that you want and then
they're just going to go away and make
that
it's like the inversion it's like okay i
have this relationship with this person
i'll pretty much as you said kardashians
i'll buy whatever they
whatever they make but that's like the
kardashians putting a pole up halfway
through like during the ad break and
going like
do you want do you want pink dresses or
do you want blue dresses and then
creating what the audience wants and i
think that
that really is um if you roll that
forward
that's a good way to start to
decentralize some of the earning
potential away from big business to
small business because big business is
never ever ever going to have that
relationship with its customers they can
win on scale but they can never win
on personality the one thing i've
learned
from years of writing newsletters is
that at the end of the
day and i don't know if this is new
maybe it is but i just i see this trend
is that
people trust people and people are
increasingly losing trust in
institutions whether they're financial
institutions or media
institutions and you're seeing like i i
first hand saw people who opened that
newsletter
every single day and took the time to
respond to me and i talked to them like
a human being
whereas i don't think that most people
every day when they wake up go to like
uh you know forbes.com fortune.com
cnn.com
very rarely you probably got that you're
reading that article that you're reading
right now
because somebody on twitter that you
trust recommended it so
it's i think that there's
people are decoupling that um trust from
quality of information and i think
that's why you're seeing the rise of
things like sub stack which is the
newsletter platform
um like you said okay i'm i'm 21 let's
say i'm on tick tock
suddenly i have millions of people
and all i've done is put uh videos of
myself dancing on tick tock
the smart people use their 15 minutes of
fame
to parlay it into something else do you
want to be an investor you see these
all these tick tock kids trying to do
investing now and learn from these
people
do you um do you want to start a
business uh addison ray
who is the top the highest earner on
tick tock right now
is now going to be in a movie she's uh
partnering with the kardashians on a
product like
all these things that i think yes
you may have gotten lucky and gotten
some sort of
um fame or audience or whatever but the
question is
how are you going to do it and parlay it
into
years ahead um and kris jenner says that
every single year
she has sat down with every single child
and she asked them what is your goal for
the year and how can i help make that
happen
so it's like they are very intentional
they are very focused and they are
disciplined
and it goes i mean you can't deny
that they've been part of the culture if
not some of them setting the culture
for more than a decade it's not a
surprise that they've ended up where
they are i didn't realize just how
intentional chris jenner had been with
this
construction i now almost feel like it's
the truman show
and i'm living in like chris jenna's
world and she's like
welcome welcome back to chris jenner
globe
right yeah um you looked at bill gates
didn't you obviously there's been oh was
it melinda gates or bill
uh i've done a dossier on melinda but
bill i've read profiles on got you okay
what's interesting about their
relationship
um very interesting so okay so that's
another example of people
like i'm very curious you're two very
very influential and powerful people you
do your work together
how like how and so
i uh saw something i read everything
that's ever been written about melinda
gates and and that involved you know
some conversations with bill as well
but um she basically said criticize and
private
but when you're in public you've got to
be a united front
like um they they argue
they they fight like any people
any couple but when they're in public
they're
united and then they uh resolve their
issues
uh sorry they're united in public but
they resolve their issues on private
and i think that that is so important
because we all know the people
who go out in public hang out with their
friends and just constantly bickering
they're not on the same page
okay now imagine doing that but like
with 10 cameras in your face and
tabloids and newspapers and whatever
that is a recipe for disaster and i um i
remember taking a journalism class in
college
and my professor told me that basically
the best
editors um they they um
they criticize like uh in
in person they talk to you when they
criticize and they put the the
compliments and the praise in writing
because you're probably gonna keep that
uh the criticisms if you put it in
writing it kind of
it's a hit every time you look at it so
i
i find the same thing and i think there
was one thing melinda said that
at their wedding i think it was bill's
parents gave them this statue of two
birds
looking in the same direction and they
still have it at their house outside of
their house
and the whole idea is like we're going
to feel differently
about everything all the time and we're
going to have different opinions and
perspectives and
whatever the point though of marriage is
to
always be looking at the in the same
direction and that means having the same
foundational values having the same
goal or similar goals and helping each
other get there
um i just i think that's a very powerful
way to
think about if you're ever going to be
in a relationship let alone a
relationship where like
um when you argue billions of dollars
are at stake
the externality of most relationship
arguments isn't like a significant
portion of the us gdp
exactly i had george on the show uh
towards the back end of last year
and he talked about the single unifying
principle
that guides every decision elon makes
and that also guides every decision that
jeff bezos makes or
made i guess now uh and he said
everything that elon does gets put
through one question filter and it's
does this get us closer to mars
and everything that jeff bezos does gets
put through
one filter and it's does this improve
the customer experience
and what i think increasingly you're
seeing
is the the beauty of simplicity with
these people that if you were trying to
keep tabs on all of the different
knobs and and dials and charts as
bill gates or elon musk or whoever
you're just going to lose your way
whereas if you come at it from very very
foundational
the same with bill and melinda gates
like imagine how much press attention
how many interview requests
all the different uh responsibilities
they've got with their foundations and
stuff like that it's like
they'll have they may be explicit they
may not but they'll have a couple of
foundational principles
and that just allows you to cut through
so much of the [ __ ]
i really hope i keep on banging on about
it but i really hope that everyone
that's listening
has been working away trying to discover
their core values taylor pearson
core values just google it taylor
pearson core values it'll take you half
a day
and you will have a list of five core
values um and it changes everything
because you realize that every decision
that you try and come up with
oh should it be this blue car or this
red car should i have cheesecake or
should i not should i train should i not
do i want to go on holiday do i know all
of this stuff is
created by those values that drive your
life
and the more succinct and the more uh
precise that you can get around those
the more exact you can get around those
i think it makes everything easier from
there on out
it seems like bill and melinda gates
were doing that as well exactly i just i
think
we all try to invite a lot of complexity
into our lives
where if you boil things down to it's
very very basic things i forget who
told us this but when uh anthony and i
first got married
the the best piece of advice i heard was
get a piece of paper and draw a line in
the middle
and on um one side right like
what are your you both right like what
are your non-negotiables
like what will cause this to come to an
end
and if it's not like you know but like
the the biggest things are typically you
know infidelity physical abuse like
things like that that are
very very you cannot forgive the other
person what are you those for
you everything else that's like
you didn't do the dishes today okay well
this cause
ask yourself the question will this
cause us to break up
if no find a way to move on um it's not
the end of the world and i think like
actually it sounds simple but like
sometimes that simplicity just puts
things in perspective
i agree what are some of the common
themes among all of their high
performers that you've covered
are there any sort of common threads
that you come up against
yeah um one of the common threads uh
that you and i have talked about
is the ability to reinvent yourself
in the willingness to do it i think that
there's a lot of people who
when they fail or they make a mistake or
um they're at the the peak of their
success and
all and they lose it all um there is a
feeling of
oh what like i can just sit here and
wallow
in the fact that i tried it did not work
out
but i'm just gonna you know get a
regular job or whatever whatever it may
be for you
but i think the most exceptional people
succeed fail learn
succeed again and and then like whatever
wherever it takes you but the whole
point is the people who are able to
bounce back
and i think that that is surprisingly
rare to be honest um
i find people like sarah blakely who
founded spanx really interesting
because when she was growing up her dad
would have
everybody go around the table and share
one thing
that they failed at that day and failure
however you defined it at 12 years old
right um
so she was like he would genuinely be
disappointed if i didn't have like a
good juicy failure to share
because if you don't have a good juicy
failure it means that you didn't try
hard enough um that day or you didn't
take a risk or whatever it may be
but so because she had that foundation
when she was growing up
when she started spanx or before she
started spanx
she always wanted to be a trial attorney
but then she bombed the lsat
she wanted to be goofy at disney world
but she wasn't tall enough to fit in the
costume so like
all of these stupid things and she was
like oh my god
um but but she didn't give up in the
face of failure and then
she has this quote that i just like
always think about is
um she says well if i had aced
the lsat spanx wouldn't exist today so
like
yes if if you had succeeded at the one
thing you so badly wanted to
this other path wouldn't have been known
to you um
so i i think like they are willing to
reinvent themselves
and they they frame failure as
you didn't try hard enough and not i
failed and i am miserable and i'm stupid
and i
can't do this again um the other thing
is that
they whenever they lack self-esteem
or confidence and we touched on this
with the alter egos
they create a persona that's
it's not even an alter ego it's an
aspirational self
so for example beyonce was super
introverted
and uh shy before just all her in her
normal life
but like the things she wanted to do
which was you know
sing in front of hundreds of thousands
of people on stage
she had to be confident and she had to
appear that she had this like
massive energy you know like bigger than
life uh persona
so she created sasha fears to be like
okay
in my life i'm beyonce but on stage i'm
sasha fears i'm gonna and
i'm gonna embody this character and to
her it was like a character like it
wasn't
her um kobe did this with the black
mamba
at a time when people were booing kobe
off the car at his lowest moment in his
career
he created something called the black
mamba which allowed him when he's on the
court he's like i'm not taking this
personally
because i'm not kobe right now i'm the
black mamba so
over time these aspirational cells
kind of trend towards them right and we
end up becoming these people
i was the same way i hate it i was so
nervous like i
we would never be able to do this right
now if you had met me 10 years ago
because i was so nervous my voice would
shake i would get red i would start
sweating like it wasn't good but i knew
that
in order to succeed in any sort of field
i needed to be a good public speaker and
i needed to learn
how to express myself so i started
practicing
but whenever i went on stage i would be
like i'm paulina this like important
journalist who's doing her job
and when i would step off stage i still
remember thinking
god like i wish that in my daily life i
could have
that that i have on stage which is so
weird to think
but i think over time you start to um
get closer to that aspirational self
that's awesome
what have you failed at over the last
couple of weeks is there a failure that
comes to mind
over the last couple of weeks yeah
you're supposed to have what you're
supposed to have a big failure per day
oh god let me think of a big juicy one
i haven't so i one of my friends asked
me this question the reason i ask is one
of my buddies asked me this question
about a year ago
and i was like dude
i can't think of i mean it sounds like
such a privileged position it's like oh
no
like everything's just going so well and
it's like obviously not that
everything's going so well
but it did make me think and everyone
that's listening as well think
what have you failed at recently
what comes to mind as a failure and i
started to
assess and i was like whoa is it just
that i'm hiding my fit am i failing on a
regular basis and i'm just hiding them
away i was like no i i don't think it's
that
what is it and i was trying to work out
is it i'm not taking sufficient risks
i'm like well
when it comes to business i'm quite
risk-averse i quite enjoy being
risk-averse i'm fairly conservative with
the way that i actually treat
my sort of business operations and stuff
i like slow and steady wins the right
so that was just i don't have an answer
around this um
but i was someone for whom the dad would
be scowling at
at lunchtime or dinner time every single
day because i'd be like nope
just laid it nice and safe again today
dad yeah well so okay so i feel the same
way because i
think like um when you think of failure
you think of these like
catastrophic things so
but when i think of failure is like i
didn't try hard enough or i gave up on
something that i shouldn't have given up
on
and so for in the last week for example
i
uh was trying to get someone to be
interviewed for the profile
and there was there was promise there
was traction and then suddenly they
ghosted me
so i was like well what do i do so i
followed up
and then i followed up again and it's
like i'm not getting an answer
i i don't like that you could consider
that
a failure to get this person to be on
your
platform for an interview but at the
same time like
maybe i just you know there's maybe i
should reach out to somebody else
that i equal it would be equally as
great and i haven't done that
um i think that there's like a there's
something to be said about okay you
failed at something but like did you try
something else to recover or to go down
a different path
so yeah yeah i like that juicy one now
no i don't know i want to i'm sure that
there'll be some i'll end up with
comments below that will talk about some
catastrophic failure that's somewhat
that someone's just ah crash
crushed my dad's boat or like ran over
run over a cow and trash the car
whatever it might be um oh no
chris no that's not that's not me um
okay okay
yeah i am i do think that
the the one of the common threads i'm
seeing here is talking about this
self-esteem talking about this belief
that we have in ourselves
like realizing that failure sort of
isn't that big of a deal
and um it's so interesting because it
feels so
catastrophic at the time like
yeah one thing that i wish that we could
do
is to be able to take snapshots of how
our mental state was
in the past and like revisit them i
suppose this is kind of what journaling
is
and you go back and you read the the
sort of thoughts which appeared in
consciousness
three years ago or five years ago and
you go
oh my god i was i i actually cared about
this thing i don't even know i don't
even think about this thing anymore let
alone care about it
um and i think that's good but a lot of
the time we don't see how far we've come
and i think if we could if you were able
to plot your
consciousness's progression on a graph
i think you would have far more faith in
yourself than you do
that's why i think that writing in
public on the internet is so powerful
because it's like a public ledger of
everything you've been through
um i recently did this exercise where
i went on timing letter where uh the
profile used to be hosted on tiny letter
and i don't know how to like it's there
forever i don't know how to shut it down
i don't even know how to log into my
account but whatever i'm glad it's there
but if you look at the very early
iterations of the profile in 2017
because i know myself i was reading it
in the tone and the jokes that i was
making
and like the things i was trying to
cover up um
for insecurities that i had it was so
painfully obvious
now and i'm like oh my god like i i
really did feel like that back then and
i didn't have a ton of
confidence in my own voice and as a
writer
so i was trying to imitate what i
thought was being cool
on the internet you know and make jokes
that like aren't even funny or
that i now do not find funny but i was
trying to sound like
you know you remember like the blogger
like i'm cool like i make fun of things
i'm super sarcastic
it's not me and i was trying to imitate
somebody else
and so looking back now i'm like thank
god like at least i've gained confidence
in that
area in my life but it is interesting to
look back and be like look at all the
progress i've made
and i'm sure in five years i'm gonna
look back now and be like what the hell
were you seeing on chris's podcast
yeah maybe maybe polina thank you very
much for coming on this has been awesome
deconstructing some of the
the high performing people's habits if
the
listeners want to check out more of your
stuff where should they go
oh readtheprofile.com readtheprofile.com
that's it fantastic it'll be linked
it'll be linked in the show notes below
um i really look forward to to doing
this again we're gonna have to find
something else to talk about
awesome it was a pleasure chris thank
[Music]
you
you